Even as transgender and gender non-conforming people become more accepted in society, they still face a lot of challenges, including bullying, prejudice, and stigma. In this episode, we speak with a psychologist who not only treats transgender and gender non-conforming people, but is actively researching how they fight back against these challenges and continue to thrive and succeed despite them. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Annalise Singh is an associate professor at the University of Georgia and co-founder of the Georgia Safe Schools Coalition and Trans-Resilience Project. Singh's research, practice, and advocacy have centered on the resilience of transgender people,
尽管跨性别者和性别不合规范者在社会中越来越被接受，但他们仍然面临许多挑战，包括欺凌、偏见和污名化。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，她不仅治疗跨性别者和性别不合规范者，还在积极研究他们如何反抗这些挑战，并在逆境中继续蓬勃发展和取得成功。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学谈话”。安娜丽丝·辛格是佐治亚大学的副教授，也是佐治亚安全学校联盟和跨性别韧性项目的联合创始人。辛格的研究、实践和倡导一直以跨性别者的韧性为中心，
youth, and people of color. She was also on the American Psychological Association's Joint Task Force to develop guidelines for psychological practice with transgender and gender non-conforming clients. Welcome, Dr. Singh. Thank you. It's good to be here. You've been selected to take part in a national. Institutes of Health-funded study with other researchers to examine how transgender people came to
青年以及有色人种。她还曾担任美国心理学协会联合工作组的成员，该工作组旨在制定针对跨性别和性别不合规范客户的心理学实践指南。欢迎您，辛格博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。您被选中参与一项由国家卫生研究院资助的、与其他研究人员合作的全国性研究，以调查跨性别者是如何接受
accept their gender identity. Can you talk more about this study? Sure. We're really excited about this study because it's the first longitudinal study that is specifically looking at transgender identity development. And the reason that that is important is because most of the federally funded research for transgender people has mostly centered around more pathological issues such as HIV and AIDS, risk, whereas this longitudinal study is not only looking at risk that transgender people might face in their identity development over the lifespan, but it's also looking at resilience, which is a really important part of coping and navigating trans prejudice for trans people. So we're very excited to be collaborating with the University of Georgia, San Francisco State
他们的性别认同的。您能多谈谈这项研究吗？当然。我们对这项研究感到非常兴奋，因为这是第一项专门研究跨性别者身份发展的纵向研究。之所以重要，是因为过去针对跨性别者的联邦资助研究主要集中在艾滋病毒和艾滋病、风险等更具病理性的问题上，而这项纵向研究不仅着眼于跨性别者在其一生身份发展中可能面临的风险，还着眼于韧性，这对于跨性别者应对和驾驭跨性别偏见是非常重要的一部分。因此，我们非常高兴能与佐治亚大学、旧金山州立大学合作，
University, and Columbia. So it feels like it's the start of a new day in transgender research. Now, as part of the trans resilience project, you have been studying transgender people's resilience in the face of discrimination specifically. You know, why do you think it's important to explore resilience among the transgender community? That's a great question. I think one of the things we know is we look back at transgender resilience and transgender research is that resilience has been an understudy construct. So, for instance, we know pretty well in 2015 how many people are getting hurt who are trans. We know that there are multiple stressors. We know that there are discrimination and barriers in housing and employment.
大学和哥伦比亚大学。所以这感觉像是跨性别研究新时代的发端。现在，作为跨性别韧性项目的一部分，您一直在专门研究跨性别者在面对歧视时的韧性。您认为为什么探索跨性别社群中的韧性如此重要？这是一个很好的问题。我认为我们回顾跨性别韧性和跨性别研究时所了解到的情况之一是，韧性一直是一个研究不足的概念。例如，我们非常清楚在2015年有多少跨性别者受到了伤害。我们知道存在多种压力源。我们知道在住房和就业方面存在歧视和障碍。
We know that trans youth face higher rates of homelessness and suicide attempts. So we kind of know all the bad stuff that's happened, but what we don't know as well are what are the multiple sources of resilience that trans people use on an everyday basis to navigate those multiple oppressions. So the way I think about resilience is it's kind of the stuff that drags you down in life. It kind of is hard to bounce back to normal. And so resilience strategies that I'm interested in studying for transgender people are really what helps them bounce back. Ultimately, I would love to study what helps trans people thrive. But I think right now in my studies with transgender people of color, youth, and elders of color, it's really looking at what are their different strategies of resilience? How do they navigate oppression?
我们知道跨性别青年面临着更高的无家可归率和自杀未遂率。所以我们大致了解所有发生的坏事，但我们不太了解的是跨性别者在日常生活中为了应对这些多重压迫而使用的多种韧性来源是什么。所以我对韧性的理解是，它有点像生活中把你拉下去的东西。很难恢复到正常状态。因此，我有兴趣为跨性别者研究的韧性策略实际上是帮助他们恢复的策略。最终，我非常乐意研究是什么帮助跨性别者蓬勃发展。但我认为目前在我对有色人种跨性别青年、有色人种长者的研究中，真正关注的是他们不同的韧性策略是什么？他们是如何应对压迫的？
As I mentioned in the introduction, you were also on the APA Task Force at Development. guidelines for practicing psychologists who they work with transgender or gender non-conforming people can you talk about those guidelines why were they needed well one of the things that we know in psychology and counseling and other helping fields is that there's not a lot of guidance and what psychologists and helping professionals should do in serving transgender clients so a lot of people are maybe trying to do the best they can and then maybe the best that they can is really harmful to transgender people. And so when you look at these guidelines, they're very basic level foundational pieces of information of how to do psychological practice with transgender people
正如我在引言中提到的，您还曾参与美国心理学协会（APA）的工作组，制定针对为跨性别或性别不合规范人群服务的心理学家的实践指南。您能谈谈这些指南吗？为什么需要它们？嗯，我们在心理学、咨询和其他助人领域了解到的情况之一是，对于心理学家和助人专业人员在服务跨性别客户时应该做什么，并没有太多的指导。所以很多人可能在尽力做到最好，但他们尽力做到的最好对跨性别者来说实际上是有害的。因此，当你查看这些指南时，它们是非常基础层面的基本信息，指导如何跨越整个生命周期对跨性别者进行心理实践
and gender non-conforming people across the lifespan. So we did have the lesbian, gay, and bisexual guidelines, but again, that's not really enough. One of the things that was really important in designing the guidelines were to really make sure that we not only talked about transphobia and anti-trans bias, but that we also talked about how issues such as racism, adultism, and other forms of oppression really affect the mental and physical well-being of transgender people. The other good reason that we had for beginning a guideline system in APA for working with transgender people was really to be very clear about what providing affirmative therapy is to transgender people. We know from the research that the more that psychologists
以及性别不合规范人群。所以我们确实有女同性恋、男同性恋和双性恋指南，但话说回来，这还远远不够。在制定指南时非常重要的一点是，不仅要讨论恐跨症和反跨性别偏见，还要讨论种族主义、成年主义和其他形式的压迫如何真正影响跨性别者的身心健康。我们在APA中开始建立针对跨性别者的工作指南系统的另一个好理由，确实是为了明确什么是对跨性别者的肯定性治疗。我们从研究中得知，心理学家越多地
are working from an affirmative approach with transgender people, the better their outcomes are. So it was an idea that was really important, and I'm glad the time has come that these guidelines are now released. Can you explain what affirmative means? Yes, I would love to. Affirmative is not tolerating transgender people. It's not being inquisitive or objectifying transgender people or making trans people educate psychologist on how to work with them or what their gender identities are or mean.
以肯定性的方法与跨性别者合作，他们的效果就越好。所以这是一个非常重要的理念，我很高兴这些指南现在终于发布了。你能解释一下“肯定”是什么意思吗？是的，我很乐意。“肯定”不是容忍跨性别者。它不是对跨性别者进行盘问、客观化，也不是让跨性别者去教育心理学家如何与他们合作，或者他们的性别认同是什么或意味着什么。
Being affirmative means using the pronouns and the names and the language that really support and empower transgender people. It's understanding that when you're working with transgender people, it's not just asking them what's wrong with their life, but asking them how they are resilient. And being affirmative, a key component is really looking at your own gender. So for psychologists wanting to be affirmative in their psychological practice with transgender and gender non-conforming people. We have to look at our own gender, what we came to learn about our gender, whether we're
肯定意味着使用真正支持和赋权跨性别者的代词、名字和语言。它理解当你与跨性别者合作时，不仅要问他们生活中有什么问题，还要问他们是如何展现出韧性的。而肯定的一个关键组成部分是真正审视你自己的性别。因此，对于希望在对跨性别和性别不合规范人群的心理实践中保持肯定态度的心理学家来说。我们必须审视我们自己的性别，我们对性别的认知是从哪里学来的，无论我们是
a person of color, we're raised to think about gender a certain way, whether we're a person living with a disability, and we think about our gender a different way. Just the psychologist's self-reflection on gender is such a key and foundational part of affirmative practice. The other piece of foundational practice and the guidelines is really knowing that transgender people, they're not a recent thing. It's not a fad. It's not a trend. Transgender people and gender nonconforming people have existed across time and culture across the globe. What about the mental health and developmental needs of gender questioning youth? This is something you've been hearing a lot about
有色人种，我们从小被培养以某种方式看待性别，还是我们作为残疾人，以不同的方式看待性别。心理学家对性别的自我反思是肯定实践的一个如此关键和基础的部分。基础实践和指南的另一个部分是真正认识到跨性别者并不是新鲜事物。它不是一阵风潮。它不是一种潮流。跨性别者和性别不合规范者在跨越时间和全球文化中一直存在。那么那些对性别产生疑问的青年的心理健康和发展需求呢？这是你在新闻和媒体中经常听到的话题
in the news and the media. How are their needs unique? Now, the interesting thing about transgender adults is life can be really challenging, right? But at the same time, when you're working with transgender and gender non-conforming young people, what this group of people has to face additionally is adultism. So adults tend to have power in the lives of young people. We know that. But when you add a gender identity that may or may not be accepted by society and families, then you've got a different situation on your hands. So one of the things that we know for transgender youth and gender non-conforming youth is that family acceptance is a priority. So we know that health outcomes, mental health and physical health outcomes like suicide attempts, depression, substance abuse, homelessness, all those things can really be moderated by family acceptance.
他们的需求有什么独特之处？现在，关于跨性别成年人有趣的一点是，生活可能真的充满挑战，对吧？但与此同时，当你与跨性别和性别不合规范的年轻人合作时，这个群体不得不额外面对的是成年主义。因此，成年人在年轻人的生活中往往拥有权力。我们都知道这一点。但是，当加入一个可能被社会和家庭接受也可能不被接受的性别认同交织在一起时，你手头就会面临一种不同的情况。因此，我们对跨性别青年和性别不合规范青年了解到的情况之一是，家庭接纳是重中之重。我们知道健康结果，心理健康和身体健康结果，如自杀未遂、抑郁、药物滥用、无家可归，所有这些都可以通过家庭接纳得到实质性的缓解。
At the same time, it can be really challenging to work with families in school settings and community settings around these issues because there can be a lot of grief that families experience as they try to navigate their child's gender identity. and schools in community settings may just have no idea about how to support transgender youth. So one of the things that we really think is important about working with trans youth is assisting them to kind of explore their gender and also making sure to advocate for them. If we know that they have little power in their lives and we know that anti-trans prejudice exists, then we've got to be strong advocates in when we're dealing with medical settings, school settings, family settings, you name it. Now, the task force that we talked about did address guidelines for adults working with gender questioning youth. What should parents and school officials know and how can they make sure these children feel safe?
与此同时，围绕这些问题与学校和社区环境中的家庭合作可能非常具有挑战性，因为当家庭试图理解其孩子的性别认同合时，可能会经历大量的悲伤。而社区环境中的学校可能根本不知道如何支持跨性别青年。因此，我们认为在与跨性别青年合作时非常重要的一点是协助他们探索自己的性别，同时也确保为他们发声。如果我们知道他们在生活中权力很小，并且我们知道反跨性别偏见的存在，那么我们在处理医疗环境、学校环境、家庭环境等事务时，必须成为强有力的倡导者。现在，我们讨论过的工作组确实提出了针对成年人与对性别产生疑问的青年合作的指南。父母和学校官员应该知道什么，他们如何确保这些孩子感到安全？
One of the really important things is that, unfortunately, conversion therapy is still something that's out there with transgender young people. Can you explain what that is? Conversion therapy is really an approach where they kind of advocate that the sex assigned at birth, that the, the, the child should really be kind of guided into playing with toys, dressing, and identifying with a gender that aligns with that. So, for instance, a young child that is assigned female sex at birth, but identifies as a boy, would be more encouraged to play with things or dress and clothes that align with the sex they were assigned at birth. I think that is a very considered to be a very unethical approach. the World Professional Association of Transgender Health in 2011 came out with a strong statement that those approaches are unethical.
一个非常重要的事情是，不幸的是，转化治疗对于跨性别年轻人来说仍然存在。你能解释一下那是什么吗？转化治疗实际上是一种方法，他们倡导出生指定性别应该引导孩子通过玩具、着装和认同与其相符的性别。例如，一个在出生时被指定为女性但认同为男孩的幼儿，会更被鼓励去玩耍或穿着与他们出生时被指定的性别相符的东西或衣服。我认为这被认为是非常不道德的方法。世界跨性别健康专业协会在2011年发表了一项强有力的声明，称这些方法是不道德的。
And so if you know that's unethical, I mean the good news is you don't have to do it and you shouldn't do it. Instead, you should work with families to really keep in mind the research on family acceptance. You can't use a heavy hammer to say, okay, accept your child's gender. But what you can do is share that the more acceptance there is, the better the outcomes are long term. So supporting gender exploration, helping families grieve. A lot of families believe that their children were perfect, the exact way that they were born. And so what that means is there's a lot of grief work that you're doing in therapy. But they're also really thirsty, I think, for information.
所以如果你知道这是不道德的，我的意思是好消息是你没必要这么做，而且你也不应该这么做。相反，你应该与家庭合作，牢记关于家庭接纳的研究。你不能用大锤去砸，说“好吧，接受你孩子的性别”。但你能做的是分享这样的观点：接纳度越高，长期的效果就越好。因此，支持性别探索，帮助家庭度过悲伤。许多家庭认为他们的孩子是完美的，正是他们出生时的那个样子。这意味着你在心理治疗中做了大量的悲伤工作。但我也认为他们对信息非常渴望。
A lot of families just don't know how to support their children the best. Or maybe they learned really stereotyped notions of gender or perform those stereotyped notions themselves. So helping families, helping children. develop coping strategies, really being a strong advocate for the family and the child in their interactions with school settings, with community settings, and helping facilitate collaborative medical care if that's needed. Those are really important things to help children feel safe. But the other thing is to really be able to explain that for families of transgender and gender non-conforming children, the families often go through a coming out stage that's very similar
许多家庭根本不知道如何最好地支持他们的孩子。或者他们可能学习了非常刻板的性别观念，或者自己表现出了这些刻板观念。因此，帮助家庭、帮助孩子培养应对策略，在他们与学校环境、社区环境的互动中成为家庭和孩子的坚定倡导者，并在需要时帮助促进协作医疗护理。这些是帮助孩子感到安全的重要事情。但另一件事是能够真正向跨性别和性别不合规范儿童的家庭解释，这些家庭经常经历一个非常类似于跨性别年轻人
to transgender young people. So they're different stages. The children, the adolescents, and the families may be in very different stages. So it can be really complex. But to really drive home as a psychologist that the best needs of the child are what you keep at the center of therapy and that the more that you support the child in exploring the gender, the better their health outcomes are long term. Dr. Singh, thank you so much for joining. It's been such a pleasure. Wonderful. Thanks so much for having me. and to hear other episodes, go to our website, speakingof psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
跨性别青年的出柜阶段。所以它们是不同的阶段。儿童、青少年和家庭可能处于非常不同的阶段。所以这可能非常复杂。但作为一名心理学家，真正需要传达的核心理念是，将儿童的最佳需求置于心理治疗的中心，你对儿童探索性别的支持越多，他们的长期健康结果就越好。辛格博士，非常感谢您的加入。这真是太愉快了。太棒了。非常感谢邀请我。要收听其他节目，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学协会“心理学谈话”节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。